[Musique]
pas
sa ferme
m ça tient debout
entre deux kilos
porté de 42 km
c'est chargement automatique est géré
par le pointeur qui sont déjà chères et
je ne sais moitié interface homme
machine
sachant que c'est la gestion du
de la masse a retiré un boîtier de mise
le feu
puisque feu
classe
ici on
c'est de notre gauche change
ce sera la guerre de l'eau bue dans
pour que ça s'enflamme et on certaine
pression à l'arrière du mobile
après on a de l'autre côté on a les
casiers au but
[Musique]
plusieurs bus ça suppose
ça
m 18 concours interne je sais ça
peut tirer de tout diffusion de
l'éclairant
[Musique]
bush de nax musique
des objets bonus antichars
il ya deux modes de tirs d'armes
automatiques et manuelles dégradé
scandales ont dégradé c'est le pointeur
qui rentrent les données sur le vih m et
le tube ensuite en validant la semaine
consommation sur l'événement
[Musique]
vous
c'est la partie du lot
si c'est la partie en retire
hydraulique c'est là où j'ai re
l'hydraulique du césar pour pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre l'armement à l'arrière
ici on a la partie se racontent des pgc
pour la répartition des dents les pneus
ça c'est le cadeau qu'est ce c'est pour
gérer tout ce qui est fausse mission
partir c'est quand même un ordinateur à
l'intérieur on reçoit des données
envoyées par rameau chef
c'est donner c'est donner de tirs des
coordonnées ici on a la banquette
arrière ça permet à l'équipage de pièces
de s'installer ici on a des deux
convoyeurs avec le promoteur
ici la placette
chef de pièce
peut on peut faire de la destruction on
peut faire aussi de
on désengager des trous avec des
l'hygiène ont peu de nuit on peut
éclairer des troupes à l'isoler
éclairant et
sinon la solution bâti manque de
personnel
avec des tirs tout dépend tout dépend ce
que demandent les qui concerne on appuie
en fonction
[Musique]